SERSI
Something's happening to Earth.
IKARIS
We need to find the others.
SERSI
I haven't seen some of them for centuries.
IKARIS
Did you hear that, Sprite?
Family reunion.
SPRITE
It's about time.
GEMMA CHAN
It's a really interesting mix.
Having ten characters, we're a big,
slightly dysfunctional family.
SPRITE
If this is what the end of the world
looks like, at least
we have front row seats.
PHASTOS
Well, you know what's never
saved the planet?
Your sarcasm.
GEMMA CHAN
She has the power to manipulate matter.
And she's had a long running,
on-off relationship with Ikaris.
DANE WHITMAN
How long were you together?
SERSI
5,000 years?
DANE WHITMAN
I guess you could call that a long time.
RICHARD MADDEN
Ikaris is the loyal soldier.
JACK
Dad, that's Superman.
With the cape and you were
shooting laser beams out of your eye.
IKARIS
I don't wear a cape.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
Phastos can assemble anything
out of any kind of technology.
THENA
There were more Deviants than you said.
PHASTOS
Well, I'm sure that was fun for you.
THENA
It was.
ANGELINA JOLIE
She's the goddess of war.
She can manifest different
weapons, which was very fun.
DON LEE
He's a protector.
His specialty's a strong punch.
KINGO
This is Makkari.
None of us has
seen her for centuries.
LAUREN RIDLOFF [in sign language]
Well, obviously she's fast.
But also, she's loyal.
LIA MCHUGH
Sprite can create illusions.
She's really sarcastic,
especially with Kingo.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
I would say Kingo is
a little self-involved.
DRUIG
Kingo, the movie star.
KINGO
I've directed some things too.
BARRY KEOGHAN
He's mind control.
He stands up for what he believes in
and that there shouldn't be violence.
AJAK
Don't. We don't interfere in their wars.
SALMA HAYEK
And then there is Ajak.
She's kind of the leader of
the Eternals. Her power is healing.
AJAK
This planet and these people
have changed me.
BRIAN TYREE HENRY
These superheroes
reflect the world we live in.
SALMA HAYEK
Everybody is unique and special.
KUMAIL NANJIANI
I think Eternals is the most epic movie
that Marvel has done.
And I really, really mean that.
They're really gonna see a movie
unlike any they've ever seen before.